.
Placebo-Effekt. Man denkt,
man weiß das Wesentliche.
Egal, ob Medikamente, Homöopathie
oder Sachen wie
Kurkuma, Aktivkohle, Ölziehen.
Wenn ich etwas
zu mir nehme oder anwende,
und es geht mir danach besser,
dann gibt es nicht
nur zwei mögliche Erklärungen.
Entweder, das Zeug wirkt.
Oder Placebo-Effekt.
Nein, dahinter steckt noch viel mehr.
Heute klären
wir fünf Missverständnisse
über den Placebo-Effekt,
die uns zeigen,
dass der Placebo-Effekt
gleichzeitig überschätzt
und unterschätzt wird.
Also macht es euch gemütlich,
holt euch einen Tee, los geht es.
Folgendes wisst
ihr wahrscheinlich schon.
Placebos werden in
klinischen Studien eingesetzt.
Wenn man einen Wirkstoff testen will,
dann bekommt eine Testgruppe
ein Medikament mit diesem Wirkstoff.
Und die Kontrollgruppe
bekommt ein Scheinmedikament,
ohne Wirkstoff, also ein Placebo.
Einigen Menschen
in dieser Placebo-Gruppe
wird es trotzdem nach der Gabe
des Scheinmedikament besser gehen.
Eine gängige Erklärung
dafür ist der Placebo-Effekt.
Allein die Erwartung,
dass mir etwas helfen wird,
hilft tatsächlich.
Selbst ohne Wirkstoff.
Doch da kommen wir
schon zum ersten Missverständnis.
Nein, da gibt
es noch viel mehr Effekte.
Ein einfacher Grund,
warum es jemandem
nach einer Anwendung
besser geht, ist Zeit.
Wenn ich etwas zu mir nehme,
sei es ein wirksames Medikament
oder ein unwirksames Bullshit-Mittel,
dann meistens genau dann, wenn es mir
gerade besonders schlecht geht.
Etwa bei einer
vorübergehenden Erkältung
oder bei einem chronischen
Leiden, das in Schüben kommt.
Wenn es mir gerade
außergewöhnlich schlecht geht,
dann ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ziemlich hoch,
dass es mir
bald wieder gewöhnlich geht,
solange etwas Zeit vergeht.
Das Phänomen wurde gut
in diesem Video demonstriert.
Von meiner Kollegin Juli.
Aus dem Club der Wissenschaftler,
die wie Monate heißen.
Juli versucht,
mit einem Würfel möglichst
hohe Augenzahlen zu würfeln.
Und bedient sich
dabei eines Zauberstabes,
der dafür sorgt, bei Bedarf,
dass sich die Augenzahl verbessert.
Immer wenn es schlecht läuft,
immer wenn Juli eine Eins
oder eine Zwei würfelt,
wedelt sie mit dem Zauberstab.
Und siehe da, schon werden
die Augenzahlen daraufhin höher.
Zumindest zeigt es eine
mathematisch korrekte Auswertung.
Über eine längere Wurf-Reihe.
Doch das hat natürlich
nichts mit Magie zu tun.
Sondern einfach nur
mit der hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass nach einem schlechten Wurf
wie eins oder zwei
sich die Augenzahl
nach oben verbessert.
Für die Medikamente heißt das,
nur weil eine Verbesserung nach
einem Placebo eingetreten ist,
heißt das noch nicht automatisch,
dass diese Verbesserung
auch dadurch verursacht wurde.
Neben der Regression zur Mitte
gibt es noch andere Effekte.
Wie die Antwort-Tendenz.
Das kann Studien verzerren,
die auf Befragungen beruhen.
Vor allem, wenn die
Befragten etwas zugeben sollen.
Was gesellschaftlich
nicht akzeptiert ist.
Zum Beispiel, ob sie
illegale Drogen konsumieren.
Selbst wenn die Befragung anonym ist,
neigen die Teilnehmer dazu,
die sozial
akzeptierte Antwort zu geben.
Interessanterweise passiert dasselbe
auch bei klinischen Studien.
Wenn die Teilnehmer wissen,
dass sie ein neues
Asthma-Medikament testen,
dann neigen sie dazu,
die Antwort zu geben,
die die Forscher gerne hören würden,
nämlich, ja, es hat geholfen.
Solche Effekte können dazu führen,
dass man sowohl
die Wirkung eines Medikaments
als auch den
Placebo-Effekt überschätzt.
Missverständnis Nummer 2.
In dieser Meta-Analyse
wurden über 200 klinische Studien
zusammengefasst,
die nicht nur Medikament
und Placebo verglichen hatten.
Sondern Medikament, Placebo
und gar keine Behandlung.
Ursprünglich ging
es in den meisten Studien darum,
ob das Medikament
besser wirkt als ein Placebo.
Die Daten wurden
nun aber darauf untersucht,
ob ein Placebo besser
wirkt als gar nichts.
Die Ergebnisse:
In klinischen Studien,
wo echte Patienten auf diese Art
behandelt und verglichen werden,
gab es nur bei sehr wenigen Leiden
einen nachweisbaren Placebo-Effekt.
Wirklich eindeutig war es
nur bei Schmerzen und Übelkeit.
Der Placebo-Effekt
war subjektiv größer als objektiv.
Wenn man die Patienten befragte,
dann sagten viele,
ja, mir geht es besser.
Aber physiologische Tests
zeigten das nicht unbedingt.
Beispiel: Nach einem
Placebo-Asthma-Spray
fühlten sich viele Patienten besser,
aber eine tatsächliche
Verbesserung der Atemfunktion
konnte man nicht messen.
Und das führt viele
zum nächsten Missverständnis.
Es ist viel abgefahrener.
Das ist Morphin. Eine Rauschmittel.
Das aber auch als Schmerzmittel
für starke Schmerzen zugelassen ist.
Es hat strukturelle
Ähnlichkeiten mit Heroin.
Eine bekannte Droge,
die in England aber auch
als Schmerzmittel zugelassen ist.
In bestimmten Notfällen.
Chemisch zählen dieses
schmerzlindernden Stoffe
zu den Opioiden.
Die wirken,
indem sie die Opioid-Rezeptoren
in unserem Körper aktivieren.
Das hier ist Naloxon.
Das könnte von der
Struktur auch ein Opioid sein.
Aber es wirkt genau gegenteilig.
Da es chemisch
so ähnlich ist, blockiert Naloxon
die Opioid-Rezeptoren im Körper.
So dass Opioide nicht mehr wirken.
Damit kann man auch Menschen
mit einer
Heroin-Überdosis das Leben retten.
In den 70ern machten Wissenschaftler
eine spektakuläre Entdeckung.
Sie gaben Patienten,
die unter Schmerzen litten,
Schmerz-Placebos, wodurch
deren Schmerzen gelindert wurden.
Gab man den Patienten jetzt
aber Schmerz-Placebos plus Naloxon
wirkten die Placebos nicht mehr.
Und zwar ist Folgendes passiert,
man kann Opioide nicht nur einnehmen.
Der Körper kann
auch eigene Opioide herstellen.
Körpereigene Schmerzmittel.
Genau das passiert,
wenn man ein Medikament
oder ein Placebo einnimmt,
von dem man erwartet,
dass es Schmerzen lindert.
Die körperliche Schmerzreaktion
ist auch keine Einbildung.
Da werden Signale vom
Rückenmark ins Gehirn geleitet.
Und genau da greifen Opioide ein.
Sie hemmen die Weiterleitung
und lindern so den Schmerz.
Die Wirkung des
Placebo-Effektes gegen Schmerzen
und gegen einige andere
subjektive Symptome ist echt.
Missverständnis Nummer 4.
Unser gängiges Verständnis
von Placebo-Effekt
ist eine
selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung.
Wenn mir jemand sagt, dieses
Medikament lindert Schmerzen,
dann kann alleine diese Erwartung
entsprechende
körperliche Reaktionen auslösen.
Dabei ist es nur
einer von drei Hauptfaktoren.
Neben der Erwartung spielt auch
das Arzt-Patienten-Verhältnis
eine wichtige Rolle.
Studien zeigen,
dass die wahrgenommene
Kompetenz meines Behandlers,
sei es die Ärztin, Physiotherapeutin,
auch ihre positive Körpersprache,
Augenkontakt, Lächeln, dass das
allein schon Schmerzen lindert.
Genau hier liegt auch die große
Stärke der alternativen Medizin.
Deren vermeintliche Arzneimittel
sind zwar
pharmakologisch großer Quatsch.
Aber diese intensiven Gespräche
mit den Patienten helfen bereits.
Der dritte große Faktor
ist Konditionierung.
Man könnte auch sagen, Lernen.
Beim Stichwort Lernen
denken wir oft an einen bewussten,
ziemlich anstrengenden Prozess.
Aber neurologisch funktioniert
Lernen auch unbewusst.
Über Konditionierung.
Konditionierung kennt ihr noch von
unserem Video über Slot-Machines.
Man drückt auf
den Knopf, wird dafür belohnt,
und man will
dann halt noch mal drücken.
Wiederholt sich das oft genug,
ist der Zusammenhang zwischen Knopf
und Belohnung fest verknüpft.
Und man ist konditioniert.
Dasselbe Prinzip
funktioniert auch mit Bestrafungen.
Oder mit unangenehmen Konsequenzen.
Das einfachste Beispiel ist
das Lernen von Geschmacks-Aversionen.
Gibt man Ratten
eine neue Geschmacksrichtung
und gleichzeitig etwas,
von dem ihnen schlecht wird,
dann hat die Ratte bald keine Lust
mehr auf diese Geschmacksrichtung.
Noch krasser ist das Beispiel
von unserer Grafikerin Melanie.
Es gibt ein paar Mailab-Videos,
die kann ich
mir ganz schlecht angucken.
Weil mir immer direkt übel wird.
Das liegt daran, dass ich
die animiert habe in der Zeit,
als ich gerade schwanger war.
Vor allen Dingen in
der Anfangszeit der Schwangerschaft.
Da hatte ich mit Übelkeit zu kämpfen.
Wenn ich mir die Videos heute
angucke oder Bilder davon sehe,
wird mir direkt übel.
Dasselbe kann auch bei
bestimmten Medikamenten passieren.
Wenn mein Körper eine Tablette mit
einer gewissen Wirkung verknüpft,
kann er auch hier
konditioniert werden.
Wenn ich die Tablette
auch ohne Wirkstoff bekomme,
dann kann mein Körper
in bestimmten Fällen
mit gelernten Mechanismen reagieren.
Hier ein beeindruckendes Beispiel.
In dieser Studie
gab man Ratten ein Medikament,
was deren Immunsystem herunterregelt.
Zusammen mit dem Medikament bekamen
sie eine Süßstoff-Lösung.
Das wiederholte man ein paar Mal.
Immer Medikament,
zusammen mit Süßstofflösung.
Bekamen die Ratten irgendwann
nur die Süßstofflösung,
also eine Placebo-Behandlung,
regelte sich ihr Immunsystem
von alleine runter.
Das ist deswegen so krass,
weil es beim Immunsystem
keine subjektive Komponente gibt.
Wie beim Schmerz.
Was passiert da körperlich?
Wir haben einen
Placebo-Forscher angerufen.
Er erklärt uns:
Weitergeleitet wird in den Körper.
Dort findet das Lernen statt.
Die Verknüpfung zwischen den Reizen.
Um zu sehen, ob man
den Effekt mit den Ratten
auch auf eine Behandlung
bei Menschen übertragen kann,
führten die Forscher
eine zweite Studie durch.
Und zwar diesmal mit Menschen.
30 Menschen nach
einer Nierentransplantation.
Nach so einer Transplantation
muss man lebenslang
Medikamente nehmen.
Die das Immunsystem hemmen,
damit man das Organ
nicht wieder abstößt.
Die Patienten nahmen
jeden Morgen und jeden Abend
ihre immunhemmenden Tabletten.
Und dazu bekamen
sie einen einzigartigen,
seltsamen Geschmack serviert.
Unser
konditionierter Reiz beim Menschen
ist eine grün
eingefärbte Erdbeermilch.
Der wir einen Lavendel-Geschmack
zufügen. Das schmeckt ganz urig.
Die meisten mögen das nicht so
richtig. Eigenartiger Geschmack.
Das Ziel war es,
den Körper zu konditionieren.
Dass die seltsame grüne Erdbeermilch
verknüpft wird mit
einem gehemmten Immunsystem.
Nach drei Tagen Konditionierung
kam der große Test.
Die Patienten nahmen nach wie vor
morgens und abends ihre Tabletten.
Zusammen mit dem komischen Getränk.
Und jetzt nahmen sie zusätzlich
tagsüber nur das Getränk.
Zusammen mit einer
Placebo-Tablette. Ohne Wirkstoff.
Insgesamt zeigten die Teilnehmer
ein noch stärker
gedämpftes Immunsystem.
Als ob sie eine höhere Dosis
an Medikamenten genommen hätten.
Obwohl die Dosis
gleich geblieben ist.
Nur die Dosis an grüner
Erdbeer-Lavendel-Milch wurde erhöht.
Mit solchen Tricks könnte
es vielleicht möglich sein...
Das wäre natürlich toll.
Vor allen Dingen
bei belastenden Medikamenten,
wie sie Menschen nach einer
Organtransplantation nehmen müssen.
Übrigens, die Patienten
in dieser Studie wussten,
dass sie bei der zusätzlichen
Einnahme nur ein Placebo bekamen.
Auch dieses
Missverständnis ist falsch.
Nein, wegen der Konditionierung
können Placebos auch wirken,
wenn man weiß,
dass man nur ein Placebo nimmt.
Deshalb gibt es
auch Verfechter folgender Idee:
Placebos, die klar als
solche gekennzeichnet sind.
Und trotzdem Menschen helfen sollen.
Bei dieser Idee gibt
es allerdings ein Problem.
Der Körper vergisst
mit der Zeit die Konditionierung.
Je öfter man die grüne
Erdbeer-Lavendel-Milch
ohne Wirkstoff zu sich nimmt,
desto schwächer wird auch die
Verknüpfung mit dem Immunsystem.
Es gibt Ansätze,
diese Konditionierung so lange
wie möglich aufrecht zu erhalten.
Um den positiven Effekt zu nutzen.
Aber alle, die generell
nicht gerne Medikamente nehmen,
müssen verstehen,
diese Konditionierung funktioniert
nicht ohne echte Medikamente.
Man kann nicht einfach
jemanden ein Placebo geben und sagen:
Diese Tablette
wird dein Immunsystem hemmen.
Das funktioniert
nicht durch Erwartung.
nur durch Konditionierung.
Aber Placebos könnten
ein toller Zusatz sein,
um die Wirkung
von Medikamenten zu verbessern.
Der böse Zwillingsbruder
vom Placeboeffekt.
Das bedeutet, dass ich durch die
Erwartung bestimmter Nebenwirkungen
diese Nebenwirkungen
auch tatsächlich wahrnehme.
Man muss davon
ausgehen, dass Patienten,
die richtig
fieses Zeug nehmen müssen,
zum Beispiel bei einer Chemotherapie,
dass bei denen zusätzlich
zu den echten Nebenwirkungen
tatsächlich noch ein
Noceboeffekt obendrauf kommt.
Placebo-Forschung
klingt also vielversprechend.
Auf dem Papier, also in den Studien.
Aber ist das auch relevant
für die klinische Praxis?
Hier kommt
der für mich wichtigste Punkt.
Ein ausführliches
Gespräch mit dem Patienten
kann bereits Medizin sein.
Es hilft dem Patienten,
wenn er die Behandlung und
seine Krankheit besser versteht.
Wenn er realistische
Erwartungen daran hat.
Doch das steht im Gegensatz zum
Alltag in unserem Gesundheitssystem.
Deutsche Hausärzte
verbringen im Schnitt
nur 8 Minuten mit ihrem Patienten.
Und Ärzte beklagen
sich auch immer wieder,
dass ihr Vergütungssystem
ihnen wenig Zeit für
Patientengespräche lässt.
Die Ergebnisse aus
der Forschung legen nahe,
dass Zeit für den Patienten,
die sogenannte Sprechende Medizin,
kein Wohlfühl-Extra ist.
Sondern tatsächlich messbar.
Die Behandlung und die
Wirkungen der Medikamente
beeinflussen und verbessern kann.
Dank Placeboeffekt.
Hier muss sich
also noch einiges ändern.
Man sollte das Potenzial des
Placeboeffektes nicht unterschätzen.
Für uns zu Hause, für die Patienten
und Anwender, gilt allerdings,
wir sollten den Placeboeffekt
auch nicht überschätzen.
Er hat auch seine Grenzen.
Wer schweres Asthma hat
oder eine Lebensmittelallergie,
sollte bitte
keine Placebos zu sich nehmen,
denn alleine
eure subjektive Wahrnehmung
wird euch nicht vor Schäden schützen.
Ganz zu schweigen
von schweren Krankheiten,
wie einer
Lungenentzündung oder Krebs.
Da kann die richtige Behandlung
über Leben und Tod entscheiden.
Und wenn ihr doch gerne etwas zu
euch nehmt, das keine Wirkung hat,
oder dessen Wirkung
nicht nachgewiesen ist,
dann gebt doch wenigstens
kein Geld dafür aus.
Das könnt ihr auch viel günstiger
haben. Mein Tee wirkt auch Wunder.
Cheers.
Freunde der Sonne, ich habe euch
auf Instagram das Dummy gezeigt,
ihr solltet raten,
um was es in diesem Video geht.
Die verstörendsde Antwort:
Die Milch aus Star Wars ist grün.
Kann doch nicht sein,
dass wir uns schon wieder
über Blau und Grün streiten.
Nein, das kann sehr gut sein.
Blau und Grün, das ist so eine Sache.
Das wisst ihr, wenn ihr
unser Video über Farben gesehen hat.
Schaut euch das unbedingt an.
Aber die Gewinnerin ist Janne Blum.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass es jemand erkennt.
Aber dass du es anhand des Bildes
erkannt hast, Probs und Keks.
Danke auch an alle anderen,
die mitgeraten haben.
Es war sehr witzig,
sich das durchzulesen.
Wenn ihr auch
beim Spaß dabei sein wollt,
folgt mir auf Instagram.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
bis dahin, bleibt sicher.